there is a new trend in facebook and
instagram profile pictures chances are
you might have seen it the
voila app turns you into 3d cartoon
character like
something you'd see like maybe in a
pixar film so we tried the app for
ourselves
we took the bait and this is what we
came up with once you start seeing
everyone else doing it
you're like hey i want to do it right i
mean i think that this
doesn't look like me you look great dude
that's awesome dee i think the reason
why this app is so popular is it's very
flattering
oh yeah ted let's see how you how your
mind's not flattering yes it is
you look so young ted yeah that's
definitely plastic surgery right there
no you look like a disney disney night
or disney prince
our morning show also had some fun kind
of rolling through the look at john
langley
little angler some of them they make you
look like a baby and then some of them
they make you look like it he looks like
a youthful john langley i think alex
also participated in this yes she was
stunning she's a model yeah she does
right um
and then we roll through i think we've
got sherry here look at that
it's a little wonky wow but that's total
sherry
her eyes are like dinner plates yes
nate looks awesome oh there's minnie
nate you know what that looks like
that looks like nate's son oh doesn't it
does look like a guy who's
100 percent right he does i hope nate's
watching because he'll
text me if you're watching nate by the
way brian did not participate which is
why we couldn't show you well no he did
that is there's a cartoon look right
there isn't it it is that is cartoon
brian right there yeah
yeah yeah we don't need the app
that's the live action picture of it
in person brian that's what matters
right having a little fun with